good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
for the breakfast show here on sky news
uh wherever you're watching us after one
of the most dramatic weeks
in british politics in the end the
pressure on the prime minister became
just too much boris johnson was forced
out of the top job after nearly 60 mps
quit his government
but he's not going anywhere just yet
instead staying on as leader while his
successor is chosen and as the starting
gun is fired in the race for the next
leader this morning
growing pressure over that timeline with
anger from some of his colleagues that
he could remain in post for several
months we'll have all the reaction to
the pm's resignation from the new
education secretary that's mr james
cleverley in just a moment or two
later on labour's angela raynor the lib
dem leaders ed davey and the snp
westminster leader ian blackford all
joining us on the programme busy friday
morning it is friday the 8th of july
the long goodbye pressure on boris
johnson to go now after setting out
plans for a delayed departure
the race begins to succeed him but it's
a crowded field with up to 12 candidates
tip to run
number 10 denies newspaper reports the
pm is staying in place to host a summer
wedding party at checkers insisting he's
continuing his obligation to the public
[Music]
the former prime minister of japan
shinzo abe has been shot in the chest
while giving a campaign speech in
western japan he's in a grave condition
it's a huge day for cam nori at
wimbledon the brit faces top seed novak
djokovic in the men's semis
[Music]
a one-off new recording of bob dylan's
hit song is sold at auction for
1.48 million pounds
also coming up on the program for you
this morning a prime minister who defied
convention and caused controversy but
how will the public remember boris
johnson's premiership we'll speak to a
leading pollster later in the programme
and just what can we learn from the
gestures movements and behaviors of mr
johnson will analyze the body language
of the prime minister on the day he
resigned from the top job
[Music]
talk about all of that should we uh with
the man who is very much in the know
james cleveland the education secretary
is with us in the studio hi good morning
good morning how are you uh yeah not too
bad no congratulations
yeah thank you it's a fantastic job
education so it goes without saying
incredibly important so it's a fantastic
job yeah um just to clarify before we go
any further did he actually resign
yesterday because i didn't hear him say
resign or resignation at any stage oh i
think we can take that as read i mean i
i didn't do a word analysis of the
speech but he is standing down and he
made it clear at cabinet that um
it was a pleasure to serve the country
but now we need to get a new leader
and he expects us in the intervening
period of time to focus on delivering
for the british people that's absolutely
right why does he think he had to resign
well ultimately to be prime minister you
have to
have the ability to form a government
and when government colleagues in such
numbers are saying that they
didn't want to serve under him then that
i fear became inevitability
and it's right that he has stood down
it's right that he has um put a team in
place
to continue governing whilst the
selection procedure goes for his
successor
and we should do that i think pretty
quickly pretty promptly and then we can
get very much focused on what we should
always be focused on which is as i say
delivering for the people of this
country listening to his speech he
didn't sound as though he'd done
he felt that he'd done anything wrong
well i
i think clearly he recognized that
uh he wasn't able to form a government
that was that was that was clear um
he he's he you know he is standing down
i think
i'm sure and you're going to do analysis
later on i'm sure there'll be plenty of
people that do a word for word analysis
you can do a body language analysis
those will be raked over i have no doubt
but the fact is now that he is handing
on to a successor who will be chosen i
think pretty promptly and then we will
all of us here in uh in the government
uh focus on let's say delivering for the
british people at an incredibly
turbulent time both domestically and
internationally does he acknowledge he
did anything wrong you know him well
you've been well he's apologizing yeah
he has apologized he's apologized uh uh
as i say i'm i'm not gonna do a word
analysis of the speech but he has
apologized for the situation and he is
standing here standing down and i think
now the thing that uh that i will be
doing my colleagues will be doing i
think everyone else will be doing now is
focusing on the future focusing on who's
coming next what their agenda will be
and how we continue
servicing the people that put us into
parliament and put us into government he
feels that changing prime minister is an
eccentric decision do you think the same
well
as i say i'm focused on what happens
next
um look you will want to you want to do
analysis of what has just happened i'm
just asking yeah it's eccentric and i'm
saying i'm saying i'm focusing and the
government is focusing on the future
which is the right thing to do and the
future is about making sure we have a
new prime minister and prime minister
and governmental team in place promptly
and in the meantime continue to serve
the british people what's his role now
his role now he remains prime minister
until a new prime minister is is found
that's how our system works
i think that everyone recognizes the
incentive of doing that properly and
professionally but quickly
so that we can get some certainty and so
the new prime minister whoever that may
be can build their team and make sure
they're continuing to to focus on what
really matters and that's the people of
this country he did say didn't want to
influence major policy why did he
replace five cabinet positions
minutes before he resigned then
well he has to form a government we have
to have a functioning government
he has put people in place i looked
around the cabinet table there's a
wealth of experience around the cabinet
table to make sure that we continue
delivering government because the world
does not stop the issues that we deal
with don't stop so he has a duty to
ensure that government it's not his
cabinet anymore is it well it is until
the new prime minister is uh
experiencing policy then no but the
point is that there are day-to-day
decisions that have to be made in all
kinds of departments across government
um what he has said is he is not going
to make decisions that would uh limit
the options for his successor that would
be wrong i think that is the right and
honourable thing to do so he's a
caretaker prime minister to all intents
and purposes does that make you a
caretaker education section well you are
in the job that you are in doing the job
that you are doing until you are
replaced that is how it always works
in politics none of us know exactly how
long we're going to be in our roles
ultimately i'm not going to focus on i'm
not going to focus on how long or
whatever there are decisions that need
to be
taken
in education we're moving into the exam
results season we're moving into school
places season we're moving into
university admissions seasons there are
decisions that need to be made i've
already spoken with a number of union
leaders and a number of uh bodies in the
education sector i did that on my first
day at work i and my colleagues i'm sure
will be exactly the same we'll be
working hard to deliver good
professional functioning government for
as long as we're in place if that's a
short time or a long time none of us
know okay will you be pushing for the
nine percent for teachers pay increase
that your predecessor who is predecessor
before last who is now the chancellor uh
was pushing for when he was education
section will you still be pushing for we
absolutely uh look and uh as i've been
doing this job now for uh less than 24
hours i'm i'm going to be looking of
course at all these things including new
teachers watching it of course and look
um are you going to be probably i i i am
going to i am going to be uh analyzing
exactly all the decisions that that i
need to to take in terms of an open door
in terms of
said yes in terms of teachers pay i
recognize how very important that is
particularly in the time
of inflation uh and of course i will
looking very seriously at that and we'll
be making exactly 9 or not i'll tell you
something
uh i don't think it would be very
professional of me to start making uh
decisions on the who for making
announcements here in the studio how why
is that on the hoof uh when they because
i was appointed
well that's no excuse is it yeah i'm
guessing you think that you're very good
at the job i mean you've been in in
government a long time you know you know
why this works you know how to be very
good at a job okay i know because i know
this is what you do
is you are thoughtful you are analytical
you make decisions promptly but you
don't rush them that's exactly how i am
well prepared when i come in for
interviews absolutely
and i'm well prepared to not answer that
question okay even though you know that
the chancellor would say yes if you said
nine percent
i said i mean look you can keep asking
the same question i'm going to give you
the same answer i'm very sorry at home
if you're watching and getting ready for
school i did ask him he did um talk to
me about this party that i'm hearing
about this wedding party at uh checkers
which is the grace and favor home of the
prime minister not the caretaker prime
minister there is no such thing as okay
there's no such thing as a caretaker
prime minister he's not the prime
minister in our system there is a prime
minister what's he resigned from then
he's resigned he has resigned uh he's
resigning from his role as prime
minister and leader of the party once or
so he's not yet responsible once a
successor has been able to so he hasn't
yet resigned
is that what you're saying what i'm
saying is he's made an announcement you
can read i didn't hear him resign in his
speech well if you don't think he's
going we'll take a big bet on whether
he's still prime minister so he's prime
minister so he's still allowed to use
his grace and favor home so is it right
that he has his wedding party there well
look as i say um i don't know the
details about that i've seen some media
speculation
unsurprisingly that was not part of the
discussion that i have not got an invite
uh with him it's not part of the
discussion that i've had with have you
had an invite no no so
so so the police are not flipping
invites you get one where you go so the
so the point is look the point is he is
um he is very very clear that we are
here to serve the british people he is
also very clear that we do that until
the new prime minister is in place and
that's what he is doing personally and
we will continue to work as a say
focusing on the things we should be
focusing on which is the delivery of
good government for this country the
optics though of having a wedding party
during a cost of living crisis when we
are potentially about to go into
recession you have to accept that would
not be very good well people have
weddings and wedding parties all the
time people have uh you know it's
celebrating celebrating um getting
married to someone you love i think is
the most natural and wonderful thing in
the world and i don't begrudge that of
anybody and i know a lot of people and i
had constituents a lot of people had
their wedding celebrations delayed
because of covid and they're looking to
celebrate their love now there is
nothing wrong with that and i'm not
going to criticize it is
is it right that the taxpayer my viewers
this morning would pick up any amount of
that bill for that wedding party well i
i my understanding and i'm yeah i don't
pretend to be an expert on this i've
i've um i don't have the details about
how checkers work my understanding is
that private functions are not paid out
to the public person yeah but there'd be
extra security when there was hundreds
of people there
uh i don't necessarily know that that is
the case i think the security
arrangements of of um government
buildings are what they are they are
they are a standing cost where they're
pretty confident that there won't be any
cost to the taxes well so as i say my
understanding is that private
expenditure is not funded out the public
person okay so there won't be any cost
to the tax that's my understanding okay
and if you got an invite would you go of
course i would go he's a long-standing
friend and colleague i know him really
well i know carrie really well um but as
i say i'm not so presumptuous and i
don't you know i don't want to i don't
want to get uh i don't get told off
by uh by anyone them or mrs c for
uh presumptively
inserting myself in someone else's
celebration well i think she should
probably buy a hat just in case that is
what i'm suggesting uh will you stand
for leader
uh no i won't be um so my
uh
as you know i put myself forward last
time i don't regret that i really
enjoyed it um as you know uh my my wife
has been going through cancer treatment
and whilst that is progressing well it
hasn't concluded it's not the right time
for me
and i feel comfortable that actually we
have a range of
candidates within the party that would
make excellent prime ministers
and before you ask the next obvious
question i haven't decided who i'm going
to support yet i wasn't good what i was
going to ask you i was going to ask you
how you miss is doing oh that's right
yeah she's it's it's it's it's going
well the the medical team
guys and a team of st thomas's that
she's working with have been absolutely
amazing things are progressing well
she's uh she's um she's not quite back
to her
pre-treatment self but the treatment
seems to have been going very very well
but the boys are okay yeah it's always
tough but it is always tough and seeing
seeing someone you love go through that
is not easy and i know this is something
that touches
so many families so many women uh across
the uh across the country um but as i
say the the the treatment she's had um
the the the the team as i say both guys
cancer and thomas have been absolutely
unbelievable i cannot praise them highly
enough but absolutely fantastic and then
i was going to ask you who you can
i have not decided yet we'll look we'll
see who's the criteria we'll see look
the criteria is really simple someone
that would someone that would be
a good
uh
governor of the of um
the the government someone who will uh
be a good campaigner someone who will
form a good government uh look brexit's
done
so brexit that's right
we're almost outside that's for another
conversation uh what about one of those
um that has stabbed your boss in the
back would you still vote for them well
as i say i uh i think that we have a
um i think we've got a range of
candidates i do think actually that uh
demonstrating loyalty to others is
important if you want people to
demonstrate loyalty to you
um
and i think that that will be one of the
criteria that is taken very very
seriously
by not just myself but by a range of
people but as i say we have a number of
people who are who would make excellent
excellent prime ministers i think we're
spoilt for choice
final thought before i let you go um we
heard from sir john major saying that
potentially in order to expedite what's
going on you could uh get rid of the
grassroots vote so uh conservative
members watching us this morning would
not get a vote in who the next prime
minister would be
so like john major has an opinion i
disagree with that i think what we saw
with
uh theresa may that
testing
a future prime minister's ability to
campaign and campaign across the country
is really important theresa may had many
many many fantastic attributes but what
we saw in the 2017 general election she
was not a natural campaigner and that
was not good for government
so i think testing the ability of a
candidate to reach out beyond the
westminster bubble is incredibly
important so i think it's an important
part of the process thank you for
joining us in warm regards to your good
lady hope that she continues to be well
thank you
a quick look at the papers for you the
mirror splashes with one last party the
papers exclusive claiming boris johnson
wants to stay in post to host a wedding
bash at his checkers residence
the telegraph leads with news that some
senior conservatives frame that mr
johnson's caretaker government could
leave the country paralyzed
downfall that's the front of the eye
claiming at least 11 tories and now
considering standing for the party
leadership
front page of the times johnson throws
in the towel says the times quoting his
words when the herd moves it moves
while the male warns tory mps they may
rue the day they forced mr johnson out
asking what the hell have they done
just hearing that the former japanese
prime minister shinzo abe has been shot
during a speech in the city of nara
what's happening how is he let's find
out nicole standing by hi nicole
we have some video that has been
captured
showing some indication of what happened
during that attack you can see shinzo
abe
addressing the crowds he was on the
campaign trail
a shot is heard
and then a suspect is wrestled to the
ground he was later airlifted out
officials say that his heart has stopped
the fire department of the city has also
confirmed that he was in cardio and
pulmonary
arrest now local media says that a 42
year old man has been arrested that he
used a homemade gun and that he told
police that he was unhappy with abe's
performance and that he intended
to kill him now this is an incredibly
rare unusual situation to be happening
in japan it's normally a very safe
country
gun violence is rare political violence
is rare as well
we've also heard from japan's prime
minister fumio kishida
he has said that there will of course be
an investigation and he wants to believe
that the security was sufficient and
he's condemned the act in the strongest
terms
more international reaction is coming
out because shinzei abe
uh was really had global stature he was
a major figure on the international
stage during his long tenure as japan's
prime minister we've heard from boris
johnson he said that he's utterly
appalled by this attack calling it
despicable also the u.s secretary of
state anthony blinken speaking at the
g20 foreign ministers meeting in bali
has said that thoughts and prayers are
with his his family and the people of
japan at this time
also the u.s ambassador to japan
recognizing that shinzo abe was an
outstanding leader and an unwavering
ally of the united states so many
questions are going to be asked about
how such a incredible security breach
could have happened because looking at
that video it appears that the attack
took place in close range there doesn't
appear to have been a great deal of
security
around but more international reaction
will come out during the day
shinzei abe was prime minister of japan
twice as i said the longest serving
leader he steered the country through
through a difficult
economic period
when the economy was stagnating and
aging population in effect he formed his
own economic policy which in the end was
known as abenomics
okay thanks so much indeed nicole thank
you obviously we'll continue to update
you on the condition of mr arby who has
been shot
during a presentation within the last
few hours still to come on the programme
joined by the liberal democrat leader
that's the ed davey of course in the
studio in just a moment
then after that labour's deputy leader
angela rainer will also be coming in to
give us her reaction to the prime
minister's resignation or is it
and we'll be hearing from the smps ian
blackford
[Music]
sireed is with us now well they think
it's all over but when i was speaking i
don't know if you heard my interview
yeah with james cleverley um he didn't
mention resigning his speech at all and
he's still in charge
yeah he not only didn't he mentioned
resign he didn't apologize
and i think many people hoped that he'd
have some grace
take some responsibility and he didn't
he was blaming everyone else and
the fact that as you say he didn't
mention the word resign uh i think
should alarm at conservative mps
so liberal democrats have said he he
should go now he shouldn't be allowed to
go on whether
you call him a caretaker prime minister
he also corrected me on that and said
there's no such thing as a caretaker
prime minister so he's still the prime
minister we know the words caretaker
can't apply to boris johnson he's never
cared and taken care of anything in his
life and he should go
you know he can't be trusted
he tells lies he's broken the law
the idea that conservative mps are
taking a job in his cabinet to prop him
up for a next few next few weeks or
months i think he's quite scandalous
actually so liberal democrats will be
working cross party to see if we can get
rid of him as soon as possible because
our country needs a plan
and this government has got no plan we
need to help the millions of families
and pensioners who are struggling out
there you can't afford to put food on
the table fill up their
car with petrol worrying about the
heating bills this winter and i see
nothing i've seen nothing from boris
johnson to really address that and i
don't think we can wait wait any longer
others would say you've got his scalp
just give him a break now
no i'm sorry it's not like that
the issue is what's good for our country
the issue is what's good for the
millions of people who are worried out
there the the businesses who are who are
struggling and you can't have a lame
duck prime minister that's what he is
he's got no authority he can't take the
big decision you say that he might
well i think there'll be a real problem
uh in parliament if he does i think from
his own side possibly even from the
conservative leadership candidates i
think they'll say hold on a minute
you've resigned you've got you've lost
legitimacy and i think the big decisions
that our country made let me give you an
example liberal democrats have argued
for a tax cut we think they should be
cutting v80 two and a half percent big
bold measure to give the average
household a 600 pounds tax cut that's
what little democrats have argued for
and that's against boris johnson's
government having put taxes up 15 times
during a time when the bills are going
through the roof that's not what people
need they need some help and i don't
think boris johnson at this time has the
ability to take that sort of bold
decision that liberal democrats think
are needed to help the families major
policy decisions so of course he can't
but this is why he should go now he
should absolutely be replaced by him
well in the short term
one would have thought they'd put the
deputy prime minister in uh at least he
isn't as tainted as as the uh as the
prime minister i mean i'm not no big fan
of dominic rob and i think he's got a
lot to answer for don't get me wrong but
at least you get boris johnson out of
the way the one who's caused so much of
the problems um and then we could at
least judge this uh that interim uh uh
cabinet um but my real concern and i'll
be i'll be frankly you won't be
surprised for me to say this gay is i
think there needs to be an early general
election you're not gonna get that well
well i'm gonna push for it because i
want the whole lot gone yeah because
they should all take responsibility they
put him there they've kept him there
they propped him up when for for many of
us it was obvious he wasn't fit had no
plan and wasn't competent and that's why
and i make no apology for it i think as
soon as they chosen their leader there
should be a general election there won't
be is my
best bet
why
are you going to um join ranks with
labour to push for a vote of no
confidence in this government yeah
liberal democrats will work cross-party
with labor with the smp i think with
some conservative mps i've certainly
heard some uh really worried uh that so
you could win a vote you think
well it's worth trying uh you know
that's in the national interest for him
to go now and not to
to to to stagger on
um and so yeah we'll try everything
that's our duty as an opposition party i
think it's our patriotic duty and one of
my criticisms of all these conservative
mps who've allowed this shambolic
incompetent prime minister to go on is
they've not done their patriotic duty
they should put the national interest
first and they haven't done
what do you make of
people being critical of a party uh
wedding party that mr and mrs johnson
want to have i mean
why not
well for me the test uh and i think you
said this in your interview with james
cleverley the test is does the taxpayer
paid i think that people would be
absolutely throwing my questions back at
me no no no
if the taxpayer was paying a single
penny that would be wrong but i have to
say i think there's another issue here
and i think back to the pandemic and the
lockdowns and there were
so many
couples who wanted to get their ceremony
their their marriage uh their engagement
party and weren't able to know the
johnsons john says well they had one in
the in in downing street but a very
small number of people were allowed to
attend which is why they want this party
now yeah well that didn't happen to some
of the other parties there did it but my
this is this is my point uh the the
whole bridal industry was in real chaos
during that
and lots of people were disappointed and
i'm just thinking of how they're feeling
to be honest when they hear about this
huge big party that's going to happen at
checkers so the taxpayer is is a big
issue for me the taxpayer should not be
spending a penny
um but i my heart goes out to those
people who whose wonderful wedding times
are special moments had to be either
cancelled or could tell dramatically and
i think that they'll be feeling a bit
sore that's that's the point i'm making
and your party has done a bit of work
having a body of work about the amount
of money that the last few days has cost
the taxpayer
yeah we're really alarmed because when
ministers are appointed and then
resigned they have a payoff when they
leave office
and some of these ministers will have
been in in place for hours
and
according to the rules they'll get a
huge watch of cash just for
being appointed by boris johnson for a
few hours that is wrong that's like
michelle donald i think is
um seventeen thousand pounds she'll get
well although she has said to be her
education session for 36 hours she has
said if that's the case she's not aware
of it she will give it to charity
well no i i think
the taxpayer that who's really being hit
hard and they need tax cuts we shouldn't
be wasting money on any of these
ministers pointed appointed in this way
i think we need a statement from boris
johnson to say that none of these
ministers will get any payoff whatsoever
and the taxpayer for once by this
government will be looked after i mean
i'm still scandalized by the waste of
taxpayers money during the lockdown they
wasted billions of pounds and now
they're going to waste
thousands more
to give themselves payoffs that you've
calculated 420 000 something like that
yeah um
the the clever people in liberty mhq
have done the full analysis of uh what
this might mean for the taxpayer um it's
our job as an opposition party to hold
the government to account that's the
sort of thing we do and it's a huge bill
it's a huge bill so you did did you get
a payoff when you left ministry well i'd
served i'd served for five years and
lost my seat and and i i wouldn't be
judged that for any minister who spent
uh a serious time doing a serious job uh
because you're not allowed to take
another job uh for a period of time
because you've been a minister so that
that's what it's to do with um but our
concern is these people have spent no
time doing this job and they're going
straight into another job some are being
reappointed into another position that
clearly is wrong i don't think it would
happen in the private sector i don't
even think it would happen in other
aspects of the public sector and
certainly shouldn't
uh and for these conservative mps to get
these massive payoffs just is wrong
we must let you go we're out of time but
just
go back to that one point it just popped
into my head as far as a vote of no
confidence is concerned how quickly
could you think we might be we might see
that well we're hoping monday
to talk to you thanks so much thank you
looking at today's other headlines we
know here on the breakfast show on sky
news in the u.s the former police
officer derek shovin has been sentenced
to an additional 21 years
in prison for violating george floyd's
civil rights it adds to the sentence
he's already serving for murder he was
on duty when he pinned george floyd to
the pavement for more than nine minutes
resulting in his death in may 2020 he
will serve that sentence concurrently
parts of the uk will experience a
heatwave over the weekend with soaring
temperatures set to last into next week
temperatures of more than 29 degrees
celsius are expected across the south
and east of england on sunday with
forecasts surpassing 30 degrees on
monday
the uk hsa and met office have issued a
level two health alert warning
british tennis number one cameron nori
faces the biggest match of his career at
wimbledon today 26 year old will take on
the defending champion novak djokovic in
the semi-final on centre court this
afternoon whoever wins will face
australia's nick kirogis on sunday
soaring wheat prices are causing the
price of
gin to go flying up with warning some
popular brands likely to introduce
increases of several pounds a bottle
wheat and cereal prices were already
rising earlier in the year but have been
exacerbated by a grain shortage caused
by russia's invasion of ukraine
[Music]
the answer is
a one-off recording of bob dylan's
famous song blowing in the wind has sold
at auction for one and a half million
pounds it's the first new studio
recording of the hit since dylan's wrote
it in 1962.
it was sold at christie's in london
exceeding the estimated price of between
600 000 and a million pounds
[Music]
today is the final day for airlines
using uk airports to cancel flights
without fear of punishment as part of
efforts to give more certainty to
passengers who are nervous about their
summer holidays
joining us now with the very latest is
uh shimon hi shamani it's great to see
you haven't seen you for ages so tell me
what does this all mean
good morning yes it is great to see you
too well basically airlines are usually
allocated a slot at the major airport
such as here at heathrow or at gatwick
but if those slots go unused it has to
be forfeited which can be very costly
and complicated so last month the
government introduced this so-called
slot amnesty in the hopes that it would
make it easier for airlines to plan
ahead and stop those last minute
cancellations that we've seen as well
we've also heard more recently from the
caa that in the first five months of
this year just shy of 10 000 flights
have already been cancelled and we've
already seen heard or experienced these
delays for ourselves across many
airports across the uk so this slot um
this amnesty was hoped that it would
make it easier for airlines to plan
ahead with fewer flights and just on
wednesday we heard from british airways
that they would also be cancelling
hundreds of flights this summer that
could impact thousands of people we've
also heard from the consumer company
which as well that said it was good that
this amnesty could potentially stop
these last-minute cancellations but
we're a little bit concerned that the
airlines still don't seem to have a plan
of action of how they were going to
approach this summer period which is of
course the busiest period for many
airlines across the uk and they say that
whilst this uncertainty is very clear
the airlines are continuing to take
bookings so this is the final day for
airlines to be able to cancel those
flights without fear of punishment
okay thanks so much indeed thanks a lot
uh do you want to have a look at some of
the images in the papers i think freya's
put these together for us uh this
morning let's have a look starting with
the daily mirror um
get a load of this fish a fishmonger's
bunker down in edinburgh with a halibut
that's even bigger than he is it's over
five feet 10 inches that is in the
mirror this morning a sea of spots in
the telegraph as well ten thousand to be
precise a woman photographed here with a
top which is almost as pink as the
potatoes are sir farm in bangladesh
great photo
uh guardian ballet dancers getting ready
for a performance in odessa
in ukraine
brave people indeed now remember when
wallpapergate was the biggest scandal on
our now outgoing prime minister's plate
it's centered of course around the pm
failing to disclose a loan of 50 000
pounds from a tory donor well an invoice
from that refurbishment has now been
leaked gives us an insight into how that
money was spent are you ready i'm gonna
move out of the way
fifteen thousand pounds on two
sofas
and then
on top of that spent another two
thousand eight hundred and eighty pounds
upholstering them
why not buy them the right color in the
first place they spent
3675 pounds
on a drinks trolley they won't be able
to afford the gin at this rate 2 260
pounds on what's described as
gold wallpaper steam that off perhaps
the very wallpaper the scandal is named
after no doubt and another 500 pounds
seems like a drop in the bucket now
doesn't it but it was on
a tablecloth for the kitchen table
i hope it was a nice one now the prime
minister announced he was resigning
yesterday but what is his role over the
next few months before a successor is
decided going to be asking um in fact i
did already ask the new education
secretary james cleverley if he was
simply just a caretaker prime minister
he has to form a government we have to
have a functioning government
he has put people in place i looked
around the cabinet table there's a
wealth of experience around the cabinet
table to make sure that we continue
delivering government because the world
does not stop the issues that we deal
with don't stop so he has a duty to
ensure that government it's not his
cabinet anymore is it well it is until
the new prime minister is uh
experiencing policy then no but the
point is that there are day-to-day
decisions that have to be made in all
kinds of departments across government
um what he has said is he is not going
to make decisions that would uh limit
the options for his successor that would
be wrong i think that is the right and
honorable thing to do so he's a
caretaker prime minister to all intents
and purposes does that make you a
caretaker education section well you are
in the job that you are in doing the job
that you are doing until you are
replaced that is how it always works
in politics none of us know exactly how
long we're going to be in our roles um
ultimately i'm not going to focus on i'm
not going to focus on how long or
whatever there are decisions that need
to be
taken
in education
rob's with us but he wouldn't say
whether he was going to pay the teachers
or not
did he rob
yeah on that nine percent pay rise for
teachers that of course his predecessor
who's now uh number 11 just up the road
from where i am uh he said that it
wouldn't be responsible for him to make
policy on the hoof so plenty of teachers
will be hanging on james cleverley's
words in the months ahead i thought what
the new education secretary was doing
was trying to flesh out what boris
johnson will and won't do um in the
weeks
ahead he said he wouldn't be limiting
his options for his successor that he'd
be acting as a caretaker there's many
tory mps though that think that after
the last two days
boris johnson hanging on and refusing to
go that he should go now and that a
caretaker prime minister a separate
person should come in i'm not sure the
consensus is necessarily there in the
party to actually make that happen but i
think a lot will depend on how boris
johnson acts in the weeks ahead and if
he's perceived to be overstepping the
mark then i think that pressure may rise
for him to go and for someone else um to
come in i think a lot depends also on
the time scale for the leadership
election that we'll
find out from the 1922 committee of
backbench mps next week james cleverley
i think emphasizing that he wants to see
a new leader come in promptly also
saying that that new leader won't be him
he stood last time but pulled out before
it got to the voting stage saying it
wasn't the right time for him and that
his wife was still receiving treatment
uh for cancer i think it will still be a
crowded field though tom tugan hat the
chair of the foreign affairs select
committee overnight entering the race
grant shaps the transport secretary also
putting um himself forward so there'll
be plenty of choice
for uh conservative mps and conservative
members when we do eventually get round
to that leadership race also though just
before i let you go i know you're busy
um rob was the fact that when i asked
him whether he would be supporting
somebody that had stabbed the prime
minister in the back he didn't say
directly but he did say that loyalty was
important
yeah i think keeping his options open is
probably the best way to describe james
cleverley on who he would be backing
it's difficult because i think people
like nadim zahavi who went into
government went into the treasury got a
promotion under boris johnson for some
backbenchers i think he will be seen as
tainted as two tied to boris johnson if
you like others though as you say that
did resign i think while that will be
plus points for some backbenchers that
didn't like boris johnson for others
maybe they will be seen as you say as
disloyal so many things that people will
be weighing up i think the biggest
though the biggest questions will be
around the economy and cost of living
and huge issues affecting the public out
there as well like nhs backlogs as well
those will be the big things i think
that mps and the wider conservative
party membership will be making their
mind up minds up on yeah and who
supported brexit and who didn't for now
thanks so much indeed rob thank you
let's get a view from a conservative
grande on yesterday's resignation uh ann
whiticum is joining us former
conservative minister of course hello to
mr whiticum thanks for joining us um did
he make the right decision in stepping
down
oh i think it had become absolutely
inevitable the position had become
untenable for the sake of stability
which of course we now haven't got and
the country hasn't bought uh i did want
him to uh to remain but he's decided to
go that's it that's it now it's no good
looking back and analyzing was it right
was it wrong it's done the party has now
got to get on with it um and the country
sadly will be directionless probably for
several months
didn't hear him apologizing he never
used the word apology did he he didn't
seem to feel that he'd done anything
wrong
well perhaps he thinks he hasn't perhaps
he believes that he did not deliberately
lie that he may have got things wrong
but it wasn't deliberate but frankly
when you say he didn't apologize i have
been irritated over the last few months
hearing nothing but apologies from this
prime minister he's always saying yes i
got it wrong i apologize why you wanted
him to stand there and say yet again
yesterday i do not know he has gone now
let's concentrate on the future whatever
heaven help us that future might be but
here we are with a cost of living
increase record nhs weightiness war in
ukraine and we don't know who the prime
minister is god
um do you think he had anything to
apologize for
well i'm not convinced that he
deliberately lied but i think the thing
that he lacked throughout was any sort
of grip boris is naturally chaotic now
he should have recognized that the
instant that he became prime minister uh
as he did when he became mayor of london
let others do the organization he should
have recognized that and made two
resolutions one was not to speak until
he'd ascertained his facts and all his
problems have come from the fact he
speaks just does what he thinks uh and
then has to revise it later but secondly
he should have had the savvy right from
the stark
to say right we need somebody in downing
street with griff and once dominic
cummings had gone and i don't hold a
brief for dominic
once dominic had gone there was no grip
and downing street nobody was saying to
the prime minister shut up and think
what this looks like not how you think
it is but what it looks like and
he just didn't have that his natural
chaos i mean everybody who's ever dealt
with him knows that he used to miss
appointments um that he didn't know from
one day to the next what it was he said
he was going to do the day before now
that's fine because he also had big big
views and a lot of courage but it needed
somebody behind him getting out
organized he's lacked that throughout
throughout
he also promoted a sexual predator
are you talking about chris puncher
yes i am
yeah well i mean boris i said at the
time you know that that he didn't
realize that it had gone on for so long
then later he said oh yes he did faith
he remember um but you know once again
um he was responding to loyalty he was
responding to ability and he probably
didn't then you make a good point he
probably didn't focus
on the question that said hang on this
guy's also got some other tendencies
which could prove dangerous for the
party now what we do know is that
nothing was going wrong until chris
pincher got disastrously drunk
uh and then it did go wrong big time
people make prime ministers all prime
ministers even very good prime ministers
make appointments that don't turn out to
be so clever i won't hold that against
him what i do hold against him is the
consistent
unrelieved chaos of his time in office
so sorry just to clarify you don't hold
against him the fact that he knew a man
was a sexual predator he was told that
he was a sexual predator he referred to
him as pincher by name pincher by nature
and that was okay
i suspect that boris did not and i i do
suspect i do not know what was in
boris's mind but he didn't understand
the serious nature that he thought it
was frivolous oh well you know maybe
chris you know uh makes an appropriate
comments or something
in fact it was much more serious than
that
he was told
he was told somebody actually he was
briefed he was briefed face to face and
told that his behavior was unacceptable
and he was still promoted he still
promoted somebody that he knew to be a
sexual predator
well i as i say i think boris may not
have understood fully because boris does
not concentrate uh the extent to which
uh that man did misbehave now it's done
okay i mean this is the point i keep
making today we can go over it forever
more but it's done and the big question
in my mind is you know what happens next
who is going to be the leader how is
this country going to be run in the
interim and i must say you know you're
inviting me to condemn boris this
morning look at the people who are
laughing and gloating um the russians
for a stark barney and verhofstadt are
carrying on if you judge a man by his
enemies we've probably lost quite a good
man i'm not asking you to condemn him at
all i'm just highlighting for you the
reason that he has found himself in a
position where he's no longer going to
be prime minister and that is because he
promoted a sexual predator and and lied
about it again
it's done okay it's done he's gone
you've got what you're wanting he's
still in downing
he doesn't realize according to his
speech listening to his speech he
doesn't feel that he's done anything
wrong and the only thing that went wrong
for him was that the herd turned against
him he has no contrition
as i say i've heard nothing but
apologies coming from the prime minister
for months now the fact that he didn't
give the final grand apology that you
want is just bad luck and i have no
doubt whatever that you and the rest of
the media will now spend your time uh
campaigning to get him out of downing
street altogether contrary to all
precedent uh and meanwhile the country
is ungoverned and i'm not exaggerating
this party couldn't run a wealth stall
quite honestly
which party
conservative party that's the one in
government isn't it unless i've missed
something overnight
so they cut i'm sorry i'm a bit confused
so they were fit to be governed governor
but now they can't run a wealth store
store i'm a bit confused about what
you're saying
that they can run a workshop i'm being
totally serious i was yesterday when i
said and it wasn't a clever comment i
actually meant
that the worst possible outcome for the
country would be a labor government but
the second worst possible outcome is
this government it is humorous it is
drifting it is chaotic it is divided it
is just about every last thing that you
want from a government
we all better run for the lifeboats um
it's good to talk to you and welcome as
always
thank you very much
expecting more detail next week on how
the timeline for the race to succeed
well boris johnson with the pm is
staying on in number 10 until the winner
is announced joining us dr andrew blake
director of the center for british
politics and government at king's
college hi thanks for joining us good
morning reaction to what ms whitaker was
saying well i thought it's very
interesting defense to mountain you've
done well to find someone who's willing
to go on there and and defend the the
the current prime minister i might add
not the former prime minister in that
way i think it raises some interesting
questions though
johnson apologists of which we've heard
one
tend to claim that what he's good at is
the big calls he got all the big calls
right whether or not you buy that or not
that's a defense for him we're now being
told he's going to stay on not to make
any big calls
but to keep the ship running to keep
things going to deal with the kind of
day-to-day business which is the very
thing that even by his apologies on a
mission he's no good at so it's quite an
interesting proposition here what's
actually going to go on how are things
going to operate and how are we going to
actually ensure that he isn't required
to make any big calls and also that he
does actually behave himself because he
seems to be able to produce scandals on
an industrial scale one is rolling off
the production line every day seemingly
they are going to carry on i would
expect i think i think we can we can we
can assume there's going to be more
scandals to come yet he's still in the
job and we don't know when he's going
so i tried to nail down with the
education secretary i don't know if you
heard him chatting to us in the last uh
half an hour or so he says there's no
such thing as a caretaker prime minister
he is the prime minister so if you're
talking about the big calls he could
actually bring in policy if he wanted to
there's nothing to stop it
there's no separation is there because
we don't get to decide when we have to
make a big decision we don't know what's
going to happen if we'd have been told a
year ago or two years ago all the things
that are coming up we wouldn't we'd have
been surprised we just wouldn't have
known they're coming and that's what
government is for it's partly there to
respond to events and those events have
a habit of coming and whoever's in
charge has to be able to respond to them
so the idea that you can't bind the
hands of successors doesn't really stand
up and in this country we don't really
have these things clarified and we don't
it's quite true we don't have a clear
concept of what a caretaker prime
minister is we've not really been in
this situation but we've got someone
who's said they're on the way out we
don't know when they're going but while
they're in
well
did he say that good question heavily
implied he's on the way out he didn't
say i resign is there any way back for
him
i'm i don't i don't doubt in the back of
his mind he's right now thinking great
i've made the problem go away i'm still
in the job i at least get to have my
wedding party or whatever it is he's
planning to do and you know for him
at his own cost and his own cost good
but good good that's good to know but uh
at the same time he's as far as he's
concerned getting to the end of the day
still in the job is a win and that's
what he's done so i wouldn't be at all
sure that he's completely given up and
if you look at the history of his career
it's a series of people saying okay he's
gone too far far now he can't possibly
progress any further this was being said
when he was a backbench mp it's probably
being said when he was a journalist it
was being said when he was mayor of
london it was being 70's foreign
secretary he's now had it we can worry
about something else and some people are
probably doing that now other people see
there's still a problem and getting rid
of him might not be as straightforward
as as as he may as maybe has encouraged
us to think would he still be in power
in september
i wouldn't rule it out but i think there
will be a lot of pressure now to get rid
of him but i don't think he's going to
go quietly still he's not going to go
quietly goodness um
as far as the next leader is concerned
it's quite protracted um
form of um putting them in post isn't it
not least because grassroots
all i think is something like up to 200
000 managed to get a vote um and that
could take some time and there'll be
some uh campaigning going on as well
before that to that end sir john major
former prime minister has said we should
miss that bid out and just allow mps in
the house of commons to decide is that
possible
i think it'd be politically very
difficult
but i suppose it's possible the
alternative would be for mps to try and
coalesce around a single candidate
without having a proper competition but
i think again that'd be very difficult
there are a lot of different factions in
the conservative party that's one reason
why boris has given the job because he
was believed to be the only person who
could pull those different factions
together paper over the gaps with his
charisma now that's not working any
longer he is probably going you know
let's let's part that one for a moment
but it's difficult to know who can
actually resolve those different
disputes there's different tensions
within the party so it might be that it
has to be given to the members to
resolve it it might be difficult to get
around that we'll see
oh fascinating thanks very much indeed
for joining us much appreciated thank
you
uh meantime the rumors of who will
replace boris just talking about that
has the next prime minister are already
swirling around westminster but a
leadership election could take several
months with over 50 ministers having
their
positions uh filled in this week alone
uh there is some confusion how
government will now operate here to give
us more of an insight is wiltana former
deputy head of policy in number 10 now
director of campaigning think tank
onward hi it's good to see you thanks
for joining us on the programme what do
you think is going to happen next
well i think we've had 24 hours of
complete chaos but we now should enter a
period of relative stability uh as you
know the 1922 committee is uh due to me
to set out the rules for the leadership
race that should be published on monday
we may even have the first hustings
early next week
and that process as jeffrey cleveland
brown has been saying this morning
should be a very expedited process so we
should have hustings and votes in
parliament
as we had in 2019 and in 2016
over a period of two to three weeks
before
the remaining two candidates go to the
membership and that process should again
be relatively swift uh with the new
leader in place before september so i'm
hoping that this process is an orderly
transition i have some question marks
over whether or not that can happen with
boris johnson still in downing street
overshadowing that contest
but
at least we have now moved on to the
next stage and beyond the point where we
had a prime minister squatting in
downing street
so what do you think his role is between
now and the next prime minister being
elected
well in any normal circumstances
you would trust the outgoing prime
minister to effectively just keep a hand
on the tiller of government we did that
with theresa may
we saw that again with david cameron
while the contest happened but i think
the events of this week have really
shaken the confidence of many mps and i
would argue also officials within
government about the ability uh for the
prime minister to do that he is a
maverick he doesn't really play by the
rules and while he has given
reassurances that he will not make any
big calls ultimately he is still the
head of the government he has the
ability to make spending decisions he
has the ability to represent the uk on
the world stage um and
and i think there is a possibility that
he will try and influence this race uh
in subtle ways rather than necessarily
standing back as previous uh incumbent
prime ministers would have done is there
anything that he can't do today that he
could do yesterday
well i think the key block on the prime
minister's ability to cause trouble is
his new cabinet and they have all been
appointed as caretakers and while some
of them are boris johnson loyalists a
number of them aren't and clearly if he
tried to do anything beyond what uh he
has said then i suspect a number of them
greg clark and uh and others would
tender their resignation
and effectively forced that vote of no
confidence to to remove him from downing
street but um there isn't a formal
mechanism
but i think ultimately the cabinet will
prove uh a check and balance in this
case well james cleverley said that he
wasn't a caretaker he was he was
appointed as the education secretary and
if we saw greg clark and people like
that resign i'm just putting that out
there you know he would potentially just
fill those posts with more of his um
colleagues
well so so firstly all ministers are
there until they're replaced i mean
these are always temporary appointments
and james is right to say that uh he
should serve for as long as he is in the
job um uh but i think this kind of
pretext of all of those appointments
whether they were temporary roles until
a new leader was in place and could
appoint their own cabinet um the other
thing i would say is boris johnson found
it incredibly difficult to appoint a
cabinet and indeed there are a number of
junior ministerial posts still vacant as
i understand it
unable to appoint those roles while he
remains prime minister so i don't think
it is as simple as just saying he will
replace those people he tried to do that
two days ago and that didn't really work
um so ultimately i think this would bind
his hands to some degree what did you
make of his speech
i thought it was
much more bullish and much less contrite
than it could have been and should have
been i think ultimately
we are at this situation because of a
number of failings on the prime
minister's own behalf and he failed
completely to acknowledge those and
instead blamed the herd mentality of his
own mps the conservative party did not
want to do this it had many
opportunities to do this in the past few
months but ultimately the prime minister
forced his own colleagues hands um and
his speech showed absolutely no
contrition really about that fact so
i'm not sure it was
a reasonable way for him to go out and i
suspect history will judge him poorly
for it but ultimately that was the
decision he took
didn't say resign at all did he
he did not and that is classic boris
johnson um refusing uh to admit defeat
even when it is staring him in the face
it's good to talk to you thanks for your
insight much appreciated
thank you
so the king is dead long live the king
or queen but who might that be watch out
when the traps open in the next day or
so in fact two have already i think two
yeah two three people have already said
that they want to stun including um ms
roverman and in addition to that grant
shaps i think has also said and tom
tougenhart has also said that he would
like to be the next prime minister but
they'll have to fight off this guy if
that's what they plan to do um leaving
his home this morning are you going to
be the next prime minister
saying absolutely nothing i'm sure
you'll have plenty to say over the next
few days and weeks
[Music]